cinq mois après le fiasco français aux
jeux olympiques ils sont toujours aussi
nombreux à manier l'épée lors du
challenge de trappes environ 160 enfants
âgés de 6 à 12 ans découvre la
compétition tout en s'amusant sur la
piste j'ai fait trois victoires à une
défaite là on commence le tableau mais
enfin le truc c'est de gagner si on perd
ma c'est pas trop grave mais on va
essayer de gagner quand même cette
rencontre interclubs est aussi
l'occasion pour les maîtres d'armes de
trouver d âme de compétiteur et ça
permet de repérer quelques talents ça
permet de voir un peu aussi pour eux que
ce qu'on fait à l'entraînement va
s'asseoir en compétition ça leur permet
de gérer leur stress aussi
il y en a qui pleurait déjà ce matin et
beaucoup de monde il ya beaucoup de
pistes ya vingt pistes pour les enfants
ça fait beaucoup de monde
parmi ces talents de demain jeunes
tireurs trappistes nourrit de grandes
ambitions
vainqueur de la rencontre régionale de
rueil malmaison il ya quelques jours
simon jalbert reste serein et centré sur
son objectif malgré un premier match de
poule perdu j'ai perdu d'un point d'en
bas je suis un peu déçu d'avoir perdu
mon premier match mais je pense les
prochains matches je pourrais aller
gagner et je me déconcentre pas je
compte la gagner cette compétition comme
à reuil et j'espère que je veux faire
une bonne compétition
simon sera éliminée en quarts de finale
et termine sixième de la compétition
au classement général le vésinet
remporte le challenge de vente rats